well there's this Oliver Anthony thing
last week Anthony of course I mean of
course the guy that's behind the
Richmond north of Richmond song
uh he he put out a video I think this is
late last week maybe on Friday that got
a lot of attention and uh really seemed
to sort of divide people on the right
they're kind of there are two camps now
um that when it comes to Oliver Anthony
and and uh and especially this video
Let's watch the video first and then
we'll talk about it
if there is anything for me to address
at all with you it's that uh
you know it's
the one thing that has bothered me
is seeing people rap politics up into
this
uh
I'm disappointed to see
like it's aggravating seeing people on
conservative news try to identify with
me like I'm one of them
it's aggravating seeing certain
musicians and politicians act like we're
buddies and and act like we're fighting
the same struggle here like they were
trying to present the same message
you know I've had a lot of people reach
out to me and I tried to be polite to
everybody and um I've talked to hundreds
of people the last two weeks but it
seems like certain people want to just
ride the attention of the song that
maybe make them their own cells relevant
and that's aggravating as hell the other
thing that I find aggravating is uh
well you know like it was funny seeing
my song in the
it was fun it was funny seeing it at the
presidential debate because it's like I
wrote that song about those people you
know so for them to have to sit there
and listen to that that cracks me up
uh but it was funny kind of seeing the
response to it like that song has
nothing to do with Joe Biden you know
it's a lot bigger than Joe Biden
um
that song is written about the people on
the on that stage and a lot more too not
just them but but definitely them
Anthony has come out and clarified his
political stance since that video uh
kind of restating that he's a Centrist
and that he said it's it's the song's
not about Joe Biden but uh but uh well
it's not just about Joe Biden he meant
um it's about you know it's bigger than
Joe Biden and all that which of course
the problem is bigger than Joe Biden
um but what he says in the video is
interesting because it seems to have
divided conservatives and there are some
who say that they like the guy even more
now uh that he he this just makes them
more even more real and authentic and
anti-establishment and all the rest of
it
and it's all great and then there are
others who say that Anthony is trying to
distance himself from conservatives that
he's basically throwing his own fan base
under the bus
to appease the left
and they're upset about that
I'm not really in either Camp exactly
and here's the way that I see it first
to Anthony's credit or in his defense I
guess
um he never planned to become nationally
known overnight he obviously wasn't
prepared for the fame because you really
can't be prepared for it until you have
it and for him he went from he went from
like very not famous right he went from
very obscure to famous in in 24 hours
and that doesn't happen very often and
even if it happens over the span of uh
you know if you climb up the ladder of
Fame over the course of years it still
is it's still you get to a certain point
where it's it it's there's not you know
there's no guidebook that you can really
read that will tell you how to navigate
it
um there are a lot of people you know
there are publicists and consultants and
whatever else you know whatever people
that that claim that they're the experts
and then some of them are are good you
know do have good advice and others
don't
um but even being able to navigate that
and know who you should listen to and
who you shouldn't listen to again there
really isn't it's just you're kind of
you feel like you're on your own so um
so he's dealing with that and that's and
that's bewildering and overwhelming and
we can only imagine
also he's a he's a singer uh he's not a
political pundit he's not an analyst
um he's not a talking head uh he's also
not a philosopher right he's a musical
artist
and that's all he wants to be which is
fine that's good that's all we should
ask of him
okay we shouldn't want musicians to be
political pundits and if a musician
comes along that has a and he has a
message that resonates with people on
the right it's very much a mistake to
take that guy and insist that he become
a Fox News pundit that's the worst thing
you could do
uh we don't need we don't need to have
him defending some party line right you
don't need musical artists to do that
you don't need artists in general to do
that they shouldn't be focused on a
party line that should just be uh uh you
know uh
they should be engaged with their art
and um
expressing themselves that way
so
that's on the one hand
on the other hand
uh look nobody cares if Oliver Anthony
is criticizing Republicans we all do
that nobody criticizes Republicans more
than conservatives it's our favorite
pastime we all do it all the time that's
that's all fine okay so I don't care
about that
but just to be totally honest
when he says that he's aggravated by
people in quote conservative news
I guess there are various ways of
interpreting that but that would seem to
me very much to be a reference
to the people who gave him a platform to
begin with
people who
um you know
people who connected his song to other
people now people connected with the
song because it's a good song and that's
all on him he made a good song
but they heard it to begin with because
of conservative media and conservative
personalities and influencers
prior to that Oliver Anthony had an
audience of basically no one on YouTube
um and that's just a fact you know he
wouldn't have an audience
without the conservative media
personalities that he is now aggravated
by as many of you know I'm a true Grill
Master I love growing up just about
anything thanks to my friends at cinch
my grill is never empty with propane
because of this I can have whatever I
want whenever I want on the grill
cinches a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
tanks right to your door since delivers
on your schedule does not require any
long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere whether you're grilling for
your friends camping with your family or
lighting up your fire pit on a cold
summer night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go online to cinch.com or
download their app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Walsh that's
c-ynch.com promo code Walsh is a limited
time offer and you must live within a
cinch service area to redeem it visit
cinch.com offer for details also you
know if you want some positive news in
the culture world more since Roe v Wade
was overturned the left has lost their
mind making abortion their official
Sacrament the pro-life efforts which are
more important now than ever are booming
you heard that right despite the
narrative pro-lifers didn't go away they
increased a number as one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one's in a better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion in each state
in a post-rural America four days for
life is changing hearts and Minds in the
most blue pro-abortion States they've
had a record number of locations since
Roe was overturned and they grew in both
volunteers and locations with about a
million Volunteers in 1500 cities they
hold peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities you can help them fight the
ongoing legal Battles by protecting free
speech for the volunteers by giving a
tax-deductible gift of any amount at
40daysforlife.com that's 40
daysforlife.com
and look I'm old-fashioned I admit
I tend to think uh you know like a thank
you is perhaps more in order than
expressions of aggravation I don't know
but what really rubbed me the wrong way
most of all is not even that when he
says musicians he throws musicians into
that and he says I'm aggravated by the
musicians who are pretending to be
buddies with me
like who which musicians are you
referring to because only only a very
very very few prominent musicians ever
acknowledged that the guy even exists I
mean John rich is the only one I can
even think of there might have been a
few others but
uh and and John Rich was not pretending
to be Oliver's buddy he was he was
trying to help him get his music out
um
almost all the other musicians just
never said a single word about Oliver
Anthony at all so and the few who did
were complimenting him and supporting
him and he's saying that he's aggravated
by them
which is interesting
and finally he says that he's aggravated
by the fact that the song was played at
the Republican debate
well you know an interesting fact here
is that fox called him and asked for
permission to play it at the debate and
we know that because the Fox anchors who
were the moderators have said that they
said they got permission but even if
they didn't say that we already know
anyone who knows how these things work
already knows
you know when I heard it that it heard
it playing at the debate myself I
immediately knew that that Oliver
Anthony approved that because of
copyright law and they're not going to
just play the song without permission
I mean they could but but they're
probably not going to they're going to
get the they're going to get permission
and they said that they did so
he
uh approved the song being played and
then said he's aggravated by it
and then said he doesn't want the song
the song politicized and he approved it
being played in a political debate
so it doesn't make a lot of sense so
that's where I'm at here you know I I do
think he seems to be playing sort of
both sides of the fence a little bit and
I don't mean politically I don't care
that he's a Centrist uh Centris centrism
is incoherent it's never made less sense
to be a political Centrist than it does
today when the when the two sides are so
fundamentally opposed on the fundamental
realities of life there really is no
middle ground on these issues
an issue like for example uh is a woman
could a woman be a man or not like
there's no middle ground it's just you
can't there doesn't exist so you really
do have to choose a side you just do
period
um so centralism makes no sense but but
I don't care about that you know if
you're a musician and you say you're a
Centrist whatever who cares that's not
the point
um it's the
what could be perceived as throwing
people who've helped and supported you
under the bus
that's the thing I don't like
but then again you know the guy doesn't
have a PR firm helping him through this
that's the point so it is what it is
that's what we're left with
that's my take hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code walls to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there